welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about why your tiny
little life of randomness is
insignificant in the grand plan of this
universe which has already been mapped
out by rainbow space gods
my name is mt and i'm here today with my
big head gang brother tommy bechtold
what's going on tommy yo
my god is an awesome rainbow space guy
may he rain
with the colors of the rainbow
exactly arashem is my judge he is he
will judge my life at the end
judy is my judge pretty sick stupid
outrageous allow me liar baby wise guys
are you kidding me
judy is my judge harry was judy with you
booty yo
that booty have you seen i guess see the
pictures of her
that is the desk that's a three-tiered
wedding cake and i like it
definite celestial intervention there i
think the celestials got involved wow
[Music]
have mercy i haven't been on in like
three weeks and i've been needing to
talk about this
i know he's been holding it in for all
this time he's like yo we have to talk
about it it's the big question yes
there's no bigger question than judy's
booty i got the biggest question that's
right the question is can i clap those
cheeks with a gap
uh
all right cut cut cut leave this all in
all right tommy hit me with that big
question you got it with the recent
events of marvel's what if in the
upcoming release of the eternals i'm
starting to wonder more and more about
these giant space gods in the mcu who's
really in charge when i pray to the
star-filled sky at night that leads us
to this week's big question who is the
more powerful force in the universe the
watchers or the celestials
oh that is a great question tommy really
great question well let's first clarify
what each entity is and then we can
discuss the differences of their powers
and the rules that they live by because
you know two different groups here two
different groups of uh friends doing
different religion stuff
but yes we'll begin with the ones who
sit idly by as we primitive life forms
keep ruining multiverse after multiverse
and i am of course talking about the
watchers those
interdimensional cable watching son of a
[ __ ]
watching us as entertainment disgusting
just kidding big head gang they're
they're they're our cousins
their heads even the mammoth quality hat
couldn't fit on their heads oh
nice plug i dig it
i'm not an official sponsor of new rock
stars but an official sponsor of my
heart though i heard uh kevin feige
confirmed that everybody with the big
head is a descendant of the watchers
that's a really fun fact that's my head
cannon my big head cannon
cannon that's right but all right the
watchers the watchers are one of the
oldest species in the universe and they
are often depicted as large beings with
big bald heads because gang and pupillus
glowing white eyes it's kind of creepy
the true name of the species has long
since been forgotten so people just call
them the watchers since that's what they
mostly do sit by and watch the actions
across the multiverses without
interfering of course they first
appeared in marvel comics back in 1961
in fantastic four number 13. there
marvel's first family first came into
contact with a watcher named uatu and
he's the most well known of the watchers
and of course was recently featured in
what if
and the mcu also featured stan lee
talking to some of the watchers in
regards to the galaxy vol 2. and i love
that easter egg i've been waiting for
them to do something with the watchers
ever since that scene i'm sure everybody
has and so it's been really satisfying
to see the watcher take some booty yeah
um some robo booty the watchers just sit
back and watch because of an event that
occurred billions of years ago and that
was when the highly technologically
advanced watchers decided to help out
some of the less advanced races in the
universe and they gave a species known
as the prosilicons the gift of atomic
energy however the preschool they looked
prosilicons
i i know about the prosilicons but like
i had the pronunciation of their names
in the back of my head so when i first
read it i was i just pulled it from like
the deep recesses of my heart
prosilicons i feel like that's in italy
um you know my grandfather was basilican
and uh he used to work for the mob if
you know what i'm saying the basilica
mob he painted houses for the basilicans
yo they got atomic bombs bro they got
atomic energy give it to them by the
watcher so they they don't mess around
the basilicans would end up making a
bunch of weapons and having a genocidal
war so the watchers were like well we're
just never gonna do that again whoops uh
we wiped out an entire planet but our
bad that was their bad though to be fair
it really was uh so ever since then they
decided to never interfere the watchers
are cosmic beings so on a power level
they are pretty freaking insane and they
can manipulate the universe on a
molecular level as well as mess with
time and space so basically anything
that they want to make happen they can
make it happen and they're also
considered omnipotent meaning that they
can not only observe any and all beings
in the multiverse but they can hear
their thoughts as well and if you have
some omnipotency that lasts more than
three hours you should definitely
and of course let's not forget they can
speak directly to us the observer big
time powerful and i always find it
really creepy whenever like fictional
characters look at the camera and just
like hello you i'm talking to you and
i'm speaking specifically to uh i think
the ending of assassin's creed ii
or something like that well i think like
this this god athena looks directly at
the camera and she's like oh no i'm not
looking at you main character i'm
looking at the player our words are not
meant for you
what are you talking about
listen
i'm just like i was alone in my basement
at like 2 a.m yeah that was happening
and i was like i'm not gonna be able to
sleep this is very uncomfortable anyways
let's move on over to celestials because
much like the watchers they are also a
cosmic extraterrestrial species and
they're created at the very beginning of
the universe and are responsible for
creating and spreading life across the
cosmos but unlike the watchers they are
very interested in interfering with the
lives and actions of species throughout
the galaxy and they are also the reason
for the creation of the multiverse and
they made their debut in eternals number
one in 1976 and the celestials usually
appear as huge humanoid creatures
covered in brightly colored armor and a
lot of people like to mistake them for
robots but they're definitely not robots
like let's say ant-man shrugged down
yeah you like the micro biome and like
he was just huge these little tiny
microscopic creatures or if ant-man went
super big like that's probably a better
example he looks like a i don't know
what that man is he's like oh that looks
like a weird alien man so it's just like
a matter of perspective anyway i mean
star-lord with his star-lord mask kind
of looks like a robot literally and i
think that was intentional because he is
a celestial himself so like i think that
was a piece of fortune i like that you
picked that up i love it you pick that
up because like that's technically what
he would probably look like if he was a
large celestial he would probably go
with that
scheme and of course we had a little
peek of them in guardians of the galaxy
and the trailers for eternals celestials
are obsessed with evolution and often
encourage and observe it through the
creation of life forms as well as their
eternal and deviant counterparts and
like the watchers the celestials are
immensely powerful they have
immeasurable cosmic and supernatural
powers and also appear to operate beyond
the standard space-time continuum which
is really pesky and annoying i mean if i
could get out of the space-time
continuum i would i totally would i'd
love very annoying and they're also
considered to be near-omnipotent beings
if not fully omnipotent while they are
very powerful we know that they can be
killed or at least die and in the mcu
we've seen the skull of a former
celestial as the location nowhere where
you know what the collector likes to do
is illegal things and also the bomb
planted inside the planet ego was it
maybe able to kill him i don't know i
feel like ego is not 100 dead because of
the circumstances of his death because
you got to remember that they did use
those sovereign batteries which were
this weird interdimensional energy that
was that attracted these squid-like
creatures that were coming through um
the portal that we may have seen in
chiang chi i think that these with like
those with creatures are related so yeah
so i think that these uh annulax
batteries that
the sovereign are messing with probably
has some type of interdimensional energy
that preserved ego's life and also in
the comics a fully fed galactus was
powerful enough to take out a celestial
because you know he had his protein you
know you gotta be fully fed yeah
breakfast is the most important meal of
the day don't skip it that's right part
of a complete breakfast celestials you
gotta do it gary's way or else you're
not really powered up all right how
about some breakfast
the most important meal of the day
serving it up gary's way pop enjoy buddy
all right
all right so let's get into the rules so
both the celestials and the watchers are
immensely powerful and ancient
extraterrestrial cosmic beings and
because of their immortal and omnipotent
nature it's difficult to say why they do
what they do but it's clear that they do
obey some sort of rules and as mentioned
before the watchers sort of implemented
their own self-governed rule of no
interference after some really bad
experiences in the past and they set up
their own code and appear to only be
there to record the events of the
universe for whomever comes around after
the universe ends and when uatu
interfered in the comics he was put on
trial by the very watchers themselves
his own brothers and the celestials also
seem to operate by their own set of
rules and no one really is sure of the
reasonings and logic behind what the
celestials do marvel has like purposely
kept the celestials vague for this
entire time if they've been around they
were created by the first firmament
which was essentially the sentient
universe at the very beginning of
creation and they are fueled by the
desire to create life and promote
evolution and mutation of that life so
that it would eventually produce its own
superior cosmic beings with the power to
create universes and both the watchers
and the celestials are likely more
powerful than organizations like tva and
probably beyond what kang can control
through his sacred timeline and it has
been established in the comics that both
the celestials and the watchers serve a
being known as the fulcrum and the
fulcrum is an all-powerful all-knowing
cosmic force that has been theorized to
be part of the one above all and slash
jack kirby which is you know what marvel
likes to do they like to put like jack
kirby in their artists as like the big
cosmic beings um so both the watchers
and the celestial serve something but we
may never see what it is in the mcu
let's get to the point of the matter who
is more powerful the watchers or the
celestials well it's been revealed in
the comics that the celestials and the
watchers have been at conflict for
billions of years mainly because their
goals are completely opposite i know it
sounds weird that the celestials and
watchers were being in a fight but hold
on the watchers don't want to interfere
and all the celestials do is want to
interfere so like
you know there's a sort of animosity
there but because of the standoff
philosophy of the watchers this long
conflict has been pretty silent
it's been sort of like a i hate you for
interfering with everything and like you
know messing with humanity and all this
stuff but i ain't gonna do [ __ ] cause
i'm just gonna watch because because i
really messed up last time i can't say
[ __ ]
just watch
i'm just gonna watch i'm just watching
what it's gonna watch with the
marriage
i just
watch i really love how the slim the
watchers are just silently resenting
they're the cuckolds of the universe
[Laughter]
since the watchers won't interfere
there's no actual fighting between the
two cosmic entities occurring and that's
why it's also hard to say who is more
powerful because since the watchers
rarely demonstrate their power it's
really hard to compare it to the
celestial's power but we did see watch
you take on ultron with all six infinity
stones items that made him probably more
powerful than a celestial and also there
is an instance in the comics of
celestial's enslaving watchers to be
guardians of unborn celestials but that
is from an alternate reality comic
storyline and like usually in alternate
realities they take more liberties with
like the laws of the universe and what's
possible so we can't really say that
that is like canon what do you think is
more powerful tommy you know i
think that
there is great power in
restraint and i think celestials are
more impulsive
and more prone to making themselves
vulnerable whereas the watchers power
lies in their consistency their refusal
to interfere
and their and their and their discipline
their self-discipline i believe if it
came down to a
1v1 conflict the watchers
okay okay okay i you know what i'm
inclined to agree with you tommy because
the watchers
do have this purview or like this
ability to observe multiple universes
whereas the celestials they seem to
operate on as far as we know
one individual universe like their their
native universe right and so you know
there's different versions of watchers
throughout different universes that have
different
goals and have different ways of even
being born so i think that because the
watchers are able to observe all these
different celestial from these different
realities but the watchers definitely
have some type of one up and we just saw
watu give ultron a run for his money and
what if like right he may not want to
sweat even though ultron did kick his
ass but yeah he made him sweat yeah he
made a robot sweat and that's impossible
yeah it's pretty hard
i haven't seen a robot sweat since my
ex-wife
oh
got him oh my god absolutely
[Music]
she was a cold steel woman well there
you have it we'll have to wait and see
how the celestials are further expanded
upon in the upcoming eternals film which
is sure to be a literal masterpiece
chloe zhao is going to knock it out of
the park and hopefully we'll be getting
more action from the watchers in the mcu
soon i need to see it i want to see watu
um represent the big head gang i need
someone to cosplay okay with this big
melon i can't fit my head in most power
rangers helmets i need something give me
something but before we continue our
merchant partners at epic hero shop have
all kinds of cool clothing and gear
inspired by your favorite properties
grab a t-shirt inspired by venom 2 let
there be carnage and ride your bike
around the neighborhood getting nods of
approval from all the other cool nerds
in your area there's a lot of cool nerds
and uh um hot singer moms in your area
so just get on that bike with that shirt
and you're gonna be getting all of them
all their attention grabbing something
from rochester's merch.com is an awesome
way to support this channel and to show
the world your love for your favorite
fandom and before we dive into our bite
size questions next some words from the
people that help bring us big question
to you people like blenders eyewear
fresh from san diego california comes
blender's eyewear the only sunglasses
brand you're ever going to wear again
around new rock chairs we got some pairs
of the moon dog in black jacket styles
and everyone loves how great they look
how sturdy and comfortable they feel
they're really cool glasses and the cool
thing about these models is that they're
great to wear both to the beach and just
around town running errands because she
gotta look cool running errands i mean
are you done with those errands
squidward no i'm not because i'm wearing
these glasses chase fisher was a surf
instructor who started blenders by
selling his beachy shades out of a
backpack and his goal was to create a
cool adventurous mid-priced eyewear
option and blenders are actually
affordable so you're not going to cry as
much when the inevitable happens and you
lose or smash them blenders in-house
designers are constantly coming out with
new styles from orange polarized
wraparounds tortoise shell frames with
purple lenses to classic gold arms on
black lens and blenders also has
prescription glasses readers and blue
lights as well as a snow collection with
goggles and accessories so live life
with in forward motion with blenders
today to score fifty percent off your
blender's purchase visit
blenderseyewear.com and enter promo code
bigquestionvip that is
blenderseyeware.com
code big question vip for 15 off
blenders rocked with pride worldwide mt
i know what you're always telling me
work collaboration tools are created
equal but you're wrong not all work
collaboration tools are created equal
notion is the one tool for your whole
team to do it all notion is an
all-in-one team collaboration tool that
combines note-taking document sharing
wikis
project management and much more into
one space that's simple powerful and
beautifully designed just like me baby
group
that was amazing he's got a body like a
goddess
okay
four startups
notions can provide a full-on operating
system for running every aspect of your
company keeping everyone aligned as you
grow fast and take on more they'll even
restock your keurig for you that's not
true you will have to hire an office
assistant to do that uh we do not
guarantee that with notion ah with
powerful integrations and seamless
navigation you'll have everything you
need in one spot so you can move fast
without the silos and other hurdles that
slow companies down let me tell you i
knew a company that was running into a
lot of hurdles they're called enron
they're gone google them notion has a
worldwide network of millions of users
and is getting better all the time just
like me find out how notion may be the
missing piece your startup needs to grow
get more done and delight your team in
the process like a good ice cream cone
notion will delight your team
are you interested well you better be
your jabroni
one everybody gets a lick and everybody
gets worse
you lick
you get sick that's how you do it at
tomco all right
interested you better be want to find
out more notion is running a special
offer just for startups get up to 1 000
off notions team plan by going to
notion.com
startups to give you a sense that's
almost a year of free notion for a team
of 10. again that's notion.com
startups to receive up to one thousand
dollars in free credit to use notion
with your team that's up to a one
thousand dollar value when you go
to notion.com
startups
bam i got a notion that you should do
that all right tommy i got a bite-sized
question for you let's get it out yeah
how heavy is captain america's shield
and this is from
iajsmith24 on discord always holding it
down thank you aj smith yeah thank you
so much well first of all it's none of
your goddamn business with that exactly
i agree smith why are you always so
noticeable don't ask your shield what it
weighs uh just kidding of course
just like me the shield is not shy about
its weight as it fluctuates greatly from
year to year when looking to find out
how much captain america shield weighs
we can turn to the official handbook of
marvel universe volume one number
fifteen which was released in
may of 1984. i was released in november
of 1983. uh from my mother's womb it
provides stats for captain america
shield that claim it has a diameter 2.5
feet and weighs 12 pounds wow
it's a big baby now look at the big baby
wow marvel right it's the same stats on
their own website though they do have an
editor's note on the page that says that
information is crowdsourced
and has not been verified for accuracy
by the editors but the crowdsourced info
appears to come directly from marvel
themselves via the handbook so i think
we're okay taking this stat as canon
seems simple enough yeah well not so
fast
my bad that was a little hard after all
this stat does come from 1984 heard of
it that was the year that the detroit
tigers defeated the san diego padres in
the world series so who knows if changes
have been made in the marvel universe to
the weight of the shield since then in
our research we did find a wired article
from 2014 where they tried to figure out
how much captain america's shield
weighed in the mcu based on physical
properties displayed by the shield in
the films rhett aylin an associate
professor of physics at the southern
louisiana university roll
i'm gonna guess shannon clears i have no
idea what's your school matt's got call
it crawdads performed a series of
calculations based on a clip from
captain america the winter soldier where
cap throws his shield at bucky who then
catches it and throws it back at cap
when cap catches the return toss he
slides backwards and this is where the
complicated physics calculations come in
as if they weren't already complicated i
won't pretend to understand physics i
can barely read and i took math one
three different times in college that's
math one that's the basic one that's the
one where they're like do you remember
how to add from high school and i was
like no i don't but i am drinking 30
milwaukee vests a night so anything
that's going up here is coming out of
here in the morning i won't pretend as i
said so we can link the article in the
description below so you can check the
math yourself but based on things like
the momentum and the weight of calf the
friction of the ground the velocity and
density of the shield professor elaine
comes to the conclusion that the shoot
should weigh about
43.9 pounds that's heavy that's a lot
that's almost four times as heavy damn i
would probably throw up my back trying
to lift up that [ __ ] yeah that's a tough
day that's a big deal
no big bag of sand just like boobs feel
like remember 40 old version you feel it
and
it feels like a bag of sand
when you're touching it
i was gonna make the joke and i was like
now the biggest hole in the calculation
is the fictional material vibranium it's
hard to say how the density of this
material would affect real life
calculations but you've got to applaud a
man for his big brain approach to
answering this question so depending on
who you believe the shield should weigh
somewhere between 12 and 43.9 pounds and
that type of weight disparity could only
be covered in beautiful los angeles
california where lying about the weight
is just as easy as breathing you got
another question for me i do thank you
for that answer thomas sure my pleasure
my treasure tell me who are the dark
avengers and what would that team look
like in the mcu this is from sheriff
delane on discord thank you
evening sheriff the dark avengers
performed
not long after the events of the secret
invasion storyline in marvel comics the
momentous comics event of skrulls
impersonating many important heroes
villains and plain old side characters
will soon play out in the mcu so it's
possible we could see the dark avengers
come to the mcu a little bit sooner than
you think in the comics norman osborne
heard of him becomes the director of
shield
which he changes into hammer thus has to
manage the government-sponsored avengers
predictably a lot of the current
avengers don't want to work for the
murderous psychopath osborne so he has
to do a little bit of recruiting well
you know i mean he got stabbed in the
dick with a glider so they're like i
don't know anybody that
anybody that could have that happen to
him doesn't seem like a relationship he
only killed gwen stacy it's fine
and by the way that was
borderline arguably an accident okay
yeah
i mean it was her spine neck who really
knows yeah mind itself my spine i should
be feeling fine but i'm not undead
uh all right he has to turn to his old
pals at the thunderbolts to find a few
recruits the matt gargan version of
denim dresses up as spider-man moonstone
dresses up as miss marvel bullseye
dresses up as hawkeye which to me that
is something i'm interested in osborne
also recruits dokken wolverine's son and
puts him in one of wolverine's old
costumes he also recruits novar a cree
warrior who takes the mantle of captain
marvel current avengers century and
aries stay on the team because they
can't be bothered to make waves i like
that a couple of people a couple of good
soldiers that are like eh we don't
really want to change offices and
finally osborne himself puts on some of
stark's armor and becomes the iron
patriot
which i have theorized might be coming
to our screens in a few of the new mcu
tv shows so
if that happens
i'll be giving myself a couple big pats
on the back uh i'll be giving you a pack
in the back as well because
yeah
the dark avengers is mostly a cosplay of
traditional avengers and much like
thunderbolts their methods of justice
are slightly vicious and dishonorable
like me but what would a current lineup
of dark avengers look like in the mcu
probably a lot like the team val seems
to be putting together you could have us
agent john walker as captain america
jelena balova as black widow abomination
as your hulk replacement agatha harkness
could be your doctor strange or scarlet
witch replacement white vision as vision
taskmaster has already shown that she
could be a replacement for hawkeye true
and you know a fun replacement for thor
could be good old hella assuming she's
still alive out there somewhere and god
i hope she is because she i hope so too
and when it comes to replacing iron man
as long as you can get your hands on one
of tony's suits or even an old war
machine suit you could throw any loyal
soldier in there and they could be iron
man it might be fun to see justin hammer
brought out of prison to control one of
those suits
you know he'd be thrilled about that or
even talk zemo into taking over one of
the mechanized suits and becoming the
iron baron whoa bro i am so glad that
you brought up the justin hammer thing
bro
i would love to see justice hammer as an
iron man and i've been wanting this for
so long i've been wanting marvel studios
to make a show called the irredeemable
iron man yeah disney plus where it's
just just an amber trying to be iron man
like oh my god that'd be so great that
would be worse
oh my god i need that that's a great
call thank you tommy amazing answers and
thank you to everyone who asks bite size
questions
because that's about all i have the
bandwidth for like i just want to shout
out to everybody on discord because you
guys are holding it down we see you we
love you guys so if you want to join our
discord go ahead and join us we love you
but it is now time for our box of scraps
this bus scraps
it's a bags of scraps
bags or scraps
get some boxes scraps get this damn box
of scraps off of my lawn
[Laughter]
here's a big old box of scraps now tommy
if you have the power to create your own
planet how would you make that planet
into the most wonderful place in the
universe ooh
wow
that is a great question there's uh
lots of freshwater lakes with no sea
creatures to herm us
this docile perch and bass
swimming to and fro log cabins
everywhere for people to enjoy a serene
cup of coffee and everyone has
a healthy relationship with no toxic
traits no gaslighting no being led to
think that you're too nice or too mean
or
not mean enough or not nice enough
everyone's
romantic partner is
wired to be simpatico with them
and then
of course there's the mountains the
mountains made of ice cream rocky road
the ice cream mountains and the red
course flowing like chocolate basically
willy wonka's factory is oh my god
and what about you mt how would you make
the most wonderful place that honestly
sounds like the most wonderful place
right there are you kidding me an ice
cream mountain is that what you said ice
cream mountain ice cream mountain
chocolate rivers if you want to view
paradise bro i'm getting diabetes at the
summit my friend i'm getting
diabetes yes
oh and there's no diabetes there's no
diabetes on the planet diabetes outlawed
and due to due to a different type of
gravity everyone's bodies are stretched
out to six foot four 180 pound gorgeous
frames uh anyway i think my perfect
planet is honestly a planet full of
women like not because i want a planet
full of women to myself because honestly
well i don't know that'd be very that
would be a lot of responsibility i could
do that
but because women are just great and i
love women and today is actually the day
of the girl as we're filming this so i
just think that a world from a woman
would just be really cool i don't know
and the show why the last man a is a
show based on a comic book written by
brian k vaughan and it goes into uh the
whole scenario of what would happen if
all the men in the world died and if you
haven't read this like that comic series
you really have to it's one of the my
favorites ever really good it's
really interesting um just to see
how how much
men
have sort of [ __ ] things up uh in in
our society um not a controversial
statement it's very obvious
i
i like your uh your all-female planet
cause over on planet tommy it's a boys
club it's boys only
no girls allowed testosteronia my
favorite planet that's right
the testosterone system well that is it
for this episode of big question i of
course want to thank my big head gang
brother tommy for joining me on this
episode please follow tommy at tommy
bechdel on twitter he's an amazing man
with an amazing heart and personality
and he's freaking hilarious so please
follow tommy on twitter and of course
follow me at mastertainment if you want
to see me speak some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly follow new rockstars
wherever we are especially here on
youtube and when you do on youtube hit
that notification bell so you can get
notifications whenever we upload videos
but that is it thank you guys for
watching and we'll see you guys later
goodbye
[Music]
foreign